So I was just watching the new live
action beauty and the beast teaser
trailer starring Emma Watson,
another remake of a 19 nineties Disney
animation film,
and I noticed that the trailer ends with
two instantly recognizable symbols,
a red rose and an appeal to be our guest
from the first films famous song.
And it occurred to me that symbols like
this have come to represent a new kind
of emotional currency in Hollywood.
The currency of intertextuality
picks you out something in a text,
in this case,
a movie that is shaped by another text
that could be a film or a book or a play
or a song.
Intertextuality is something that you
can't escape.
It says oldest storytelling is.
It's how language works.
All language reaches back and is
informed by how it was used in the past.
But today there seems to be a new kind
of intertextuality born out of the
endless series of sequels,
remakes and reboots,
the adaptations and shared universities.
And it's perfectly captured in that
force awakens clip when the Millennium
Falcon is revealed,
or later when Han Solo and Chewbacca
board their ship,
or later still when bba pulls the cover
off an old friend,
what do we feel in these moments?
It's a bit hard to pinpoint,
but personally I feel a kind of free
sawn,
the chill.
Everything I know about the intertextual
object in question unloads onto my mind
like the vision ray gets when she first
touches Luke's.
This is the weapon of a Jedi Knight,
clumsy or random.
As a block
intertextual.
References can point to genre
conventions.
They can point to the texts influences
or cultural and historical contexts,
but in this new generation of films,
more and more,
the intertextual manifests itself as
objects.
People or situations specifically meant
to trigger an emotional response in the
viewer.
It's weaponized intertextuality
goodness.
What's a bit troubling about this trend
is that increasingly I'm seeing films
use this kind of intertextual reference
as a dramatic substitute.
I mean,
why else include Sour Ron in the hobbit
trilogy,
for example,
when he appears nowhere in the book.
It seems to me that [inaudible],
that whole plot line was included purely
for intertextual payoff,
so you could cash out that feeling of,
Oh,
this is what these people were doing,
decades old series are right for this
kind of thing,
and if you want a couple of examples of
just how cheap these moments can be,
just take a look at two big intertextual
reveals.
My name is ka
man.
You're talking to now a man inside your
head and stuff.
I'll blofeld
surprise motherfuckers.
It seems like this or kind of Unicorns
blood.
They'll keep your story alive,
but only with half a soul.
One of my favorite TV shows when I was a
teenager was small,
filled by its very nature of that show
was built around intertextual cues.
What made the show great the early
seasons was how it took those cues and
deconstructed them in unexpected ways.
Namely in the friendship of Clark Kent
and Lex Luthor.
Its strength was that fan service
payoffs played second fiddle to deeply
drawn relationships,
but in the later seasons,
the show began to lean a little too
heavily on intertextual objects at
moments from the superman.
Kennan,
really DC comics has always had this
problem because it's heroes are
mythological,
Batman and Superman are the
quintessential intertextual characters.
Just seeing them at all is exciting,
but the recent Batman v Superman movie
directed by Zack Snyder proved that the
free sign of having these characters on
screen together of having them fight
each other was just no substitute for
strong intelligent drama.
Snyder had a similar issue with his film
watchman.
Almost every shot in that film is a
compositional Matt to the comic.
It's trying to adapt now for those who
read and love that comment,
there certainly is a thrill and seeing
those frames and experiencing those
textual moments come beautifully to life
when that's all there is.
The final feeling is an empty one.
I think when cinematic storytelling is
confined by an economic situation like
this one,
where $300,
million dollar bets have to be safe
ones,
weaponized intertextuality is going to
be an inevitable byproduct.
I mean,
this year alone,
we have coming up finding dory
independence day,
resurgence ghostbusters,
the angry birds movie,
a Jason Bourne sequels,
rogue one,
Star Trek beyond warcraft.
Expect to be flooded with weaponized
intertextuality at every turn.
As I said before,
I don't think franchises and shared
universes are bad by default,
quite the opposite at their best.
They build interpretive communities and
foster social bonds and increasingly
alienated world.
The kind of intertextuality that we're
talking about can reflect these good
qualities.
Then when it's done right,
when it's not a substitute for strong
characters and a good story,
it can be funny excluding America and go
fuck yourself.
It can be amusingly subversive and of
course it can add to the drama while
still being exciting as hell.
Hey everybody.
Welcome to the nerd writer end screen.
Thank you so much for watching that.
That was so much fun to make and I love
thinking about stuff like this.
And if you want help me make more
videos,
you can click right below here and
pledge a dollar or $3 per video,
uh,
on my patriot on page.
The small pledges helped so much and
I'll see you guys next Wednesday.
Oh,
and thank you so much for watching my
video on taxes.
I didn't think that we'd get a lot of
views,
but people really seem to like it.
So,
uh,
so cool.